and welcome to Hannity and thank you for
being with us the New Hampshire primary
is now in the books Donald Trump is now
two for two but Nikki Haley is vowing to
move forward and coming up tonight the
very latest Fallout the polls analysis
and we look ahead to Nevada and South
Carolina now also tonight we're going to
bring you a very special interview with
vice president uh Harris apparently the
borders are has now dedicated more time
and effort to correcting her height on
Wikipedia and actually securing our wide
openen Southern border that they keep
telling us and lying to us is closed and
uh Totally Secure meanwhile despite not
campaigning in New Hampshire it has been
a very trying week for your commander-in
Chief Joe Biden just take a look we'll
teach Donald Trump an valuable lesson
don't mess with them wom America unless
you want to get the
benefit we're going to give you multiple
opportunities tonight to be able to to
decipher uh and determine what it is he
actually said there because not only is
Biden now slurring his speeches but he's
also getting heckled and getting heckled
repeatedly by members of his own party
they now are calling him genocide Joe
and that's not all last night's results
out of New Hampshire were well frankly
pretty embarrassing for Joe Biden you
have a congressman how many of you
really have heard anything about Dean
Phillips who you know few people have
heard of him he took 21% of the vote
Maryann Williamson took another 5% and
Biden won the state with what 55% of the
vote the lowest total for a sitting
Democratic president since Jimmy Carter
in the Republican primary Trump pulled
off yet another double digit win in a
hotly contested race against warmer
Ambassador Nikki Haley and between her
campaign and super Pacs well nearly $30
million was spent on Governor Haley in
the state of New Hampshire that's twice
the amount spent by former president
Trump and Haley also got a big Boost
from Independence and Democrats who
registered as Independence in order to
vote in the state's Open primary s uh
system now according to even a CNN uh
exit pole whopping 70% of Haley voters
in New Hampshire they were not
registered Republicans and still Donald
Trump pulled off a double digigit win
amid record turnout in the granite state
they had a a huge turnout and the next
contest is in Nevada uh where Haley is
not even on the ballot in the state's
caucus and then from there Trump and
Haley they'll face off in South Carolina
now this is Nikki Haley's home state
where not long ago she was a popular
governor and yet according to the real
clear politics average Donald Trump is
up uh by 30 points in the state of North
uh South Carolina Nikki Haley she's
facing a steep uphill battle so it's no
surprise that she and Donald Trump are
now exchanging barbs politics it's
simply SP spoken at just a Blood Sport
and like almost every primary the rage
well the race gets heated at some point
and it's getting to that point Haley
claims she is more electable than Donald
Trump but according to a brand new
messenger Harris poll while Trump is now
beating Biden by a whopping seven points
in a hypothetical matchup that's more
than double haly's lead against Biden in
a recent poll and needless to say the
mob the media well simply they're just
terrified they're scared to death take a
look what we are looking at here is an
extremist Maga base that is motivated by
the politics of grievance and that is
Donald Trump incarnate what did you
think about the Tim Scott moment on the
stage with
Trump I mean I've called this the the
great
emasculation of the Republican Party
Trump has completely emasculated these
guys there are few uh moments in my life
I've been more embarrassed than to watch
Tim Scott uh who are uh you know I know
Tim and I are both practicing Christians
but I don't know if he could pray like
that to to the other side I mean it was
humiliating to watch what Tim Scott did
no one will remember the margin of
Victory after last after tonight uh but
people will remember that speech which
was vicious even vile what he's offering
is strongman leadership the end of
Politics the end of Elections the end or
the or the sidelining or domesticating
as Ru Ben Gat says of the judici Jerry
uh and the Congress he'll he'll be the
man in charge and he'll get it done and
that's what he's selling and that's what
they are very eager to buy attacking
African-American conservatives that's
fair game as per usual now for the
better part of the of a decade so-called
journalists they're not journalists in
America breathlessly reported that the
sky is falling Donald Trump's to blame
year after year they predicted the
collapse of our Great American Republic
uh Democratic Republic and told us that
Donald Trump Trump would lead us to
World War III and oh my goodness he's
going to have control of the of our
nuclear Arsenal in reality the exact
opposite turned out to be true why
because under President Trump we had
peace under Biden we have War under
Trump we had almost no inflation and
record low interest rates under Biden
Americans are getting squeezed every
single day 60% of Americans now live
paycheck to paycheck under Trump we had
secure borders under Biden well wide
openen borders away away of unvetted
illegal immigrants like we've never seen
before close to 10 million if not over
10 million uh every single thing you can
think of is worse under Joe Biden
housing is unaffordable homelessness up
all over the place crime you know how's
that defund dismantle nobil laws and
reimagining the police working crime is
up everywhere overdose deaths they are
reaching record levels as well American
democracy is being ripped his shreds by
Rogue activist judges and state
officials we have parents at Schoolboard
meetings and pro-life activists that are
Marching peacefully being targeted by
Joe Biden's doj for not staying on
message and so much is at stake this
coming November about 285 days away well
I won't tell anyone what to do with
their campaigns I never have I'm not
going to start now but when the
Republican primary is over it is vitally
important that everybody come in the GOP
everybody in that caucus they better
come together to beat Joe Biden and they
better get smart when it comes to voting
early voting by mail overcoming that
resistance and that reluctance and also
Democrats they're they're practicing
something called Legal ballot harvesting
states that allow it well Republicans
better match and surpass those efforts
in 2024 so they don't start out election
night uh down hundreds of thousands of
votes hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to Subs subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else